We're here to have some fun and to do a reprise role.
...with Jeremy Scott, who did this, which I did about maybe two years ago at a house party...
...that everyone was at and we're just clowning around, that was really fun so,...
...he called me and said do you want to do it again and of course,...
...I'll always do it again with J.
It stands for extraterrestrial, extraterrestrial.
It's a song about falling in love with someone who's obviously...
...seems like they're from another world, another planet. And...
...I don't know, I guess I was influenced maybe by my foreign affair and I'm very...
...interested, I guess, in things that are beyond me in this world...
...and every time I look into the sky I think...
...I'm so small and I guess, maybe that has a little to do with the song.
I'm inspired by a lot of different things by Pop culture, by different females, by humor.
People ask me like who my style icons are and they're a mixture of...
...like, Bettie Page meets Wonder Woman meets Judy Jetson...
...meets Daphne Guinness meets Agyness Deyn,...
...so its kinda like cartoonish, punk rock, cute, smorgasbord of things.
I like to wear things that still have a sense of humor and that are adorable. I'm such a...
...collector of all things cute, anything that has like a face on it or like, you know,...
...for instance what I wore earlier today, french fries swimsuit, love that kind of stuff...
...you know, things that are I guess probably influenced from Japan...
...and things that have adorableness to them.